[Music]
in the 19th century there arose a school
of thought calling itself progressivism
a word that has by the way revived in
recent years in American politics I'm
old enough to remember when nobody said
that word except friends of mine who
were writing about these early
progressives some of them teach here at
Hillsdale College now but what do these
progressives think they believed in
progress they believed that things were
always getting better and they also
believed that change was the
characteristic phenomenon every age is
different from the age before every age
has its own thoughts and we should
accept that and seize the opportunities
that come from it what about that though
do things do change a lot right one
thing that might be a sharp difference
is that these progressives say that the
Declaration of Independence is obsolete
and yet it was a good thing for its time
they say but of course that's not what
it says what it says is it's a good
thing for all time if it's false now it
has to be false then true then it has to
be true now remember how we started out
all of this by talking about the tech
rights of Independence as a sort of
final cause and we quoted Lincoln and we
said every nation has a central idea
from which all its minor thoughts
radiate right you have to ask the
question does this new revolutionized
kind of government is it designed to
serve the principles the same principles
as the old kind is it after something
different yes and you say yes why I
think the introduction of this new
ideology of progressivism has changed
the direction of government to
protecting and deriving its consent from
the governed to protecting these new
positive rights as opposed to negative
rights mmm-hmm
yeah I wonder if that distinction works
myself but you're talking about a famous
essay by Isaiah Berlin I think there's a
lot of ways this point is put the way he
put it was- writes you can't be stopped
from doing things positive rights you
get stuff right that's his distinction
and that knee creates these agencies to
fill those needs but do you think people
should be allowed to starve
fellow citizens should be allowed to
starve no no it should be stopped
somehow right yes you think it should be
done in the States I believe that that's
a possibility yeah that's what I think
but but well the great phrases bring the
full power of the national government to
bear on this urgent problem right that's
a kind of language if you go read Ronald
Reagan's famous 1964 time for choosing
speech he mocks that phrase bring the
full power of the federal government to
bear upon it because you could help the
poor locally is we used to do and you
might even do a better job of it because
it's possible that if you did it through
the local churches and community groups
of various kinds that they would really
look out more generally for the welfare
of people or as entitlement programs
might breed dependence yeah
so you don't like that but I'm gonna I'm
gonna quote somebody to put the point in
our Constitution reader we read the
progressives if you if you look at the
Constitution reader by the way it's a
very interesting document because most
of the text that we read in the
Constitution reader are written by
people who don't like the Constitution
the United States it's always been an
argument John Dewey's argument is it's a
new world really different and as the
world changes he goes on to argue it
changes how we think John Dewey says
those principles in the Declaration of
Independence
he says those fit for a pioneer agrarian
society people thought like that right
back then and so everything's changed
now
and another thing has changed we used to
not like cancer if we could identify
what it was now there's a chance we
could cure it as we have cured many
things science is a lot more powerful we
could get rid maybe a birth defects and
if we could do that maybe we could make
the babies
smarter bigger faster stronger Stephen
Hawking has predicted that we won't look
like the same kind of thing in a hundred
years or 200 at the most human beings
will be unrecognizable because they will
have remade themselves so the old idea
and just think how starkly different
these two things are right the old idea
was we're human we're capable of really
great things as the federalists and
we're capable of really bad things says
the federalist and so we need to arrange
the government so that there's a bias in
favor of the good things we can do and
government should be limited just strong
enough to protect us from one another
and don't give it absolute power because
men are not angels true enough and they
have to have government but angels do
not govern men that's one world and in
another world is Wow look how much more
we can do by using these techniques
let's do it let's get going here right
let's solve these problems
let's get these checks and balances out
of the way let's stop this kind of
government that's offset against itself
so it's always hampered and always a
problem right that's the argument and if
you just look at the power of modern
science look at the incredible things
that can achieve doesn't that argument
have great force but I you tell me
what's wrong with the argument
I don't know that I'll be able to fully
develop this but it seems like the last
couple days we've really established
that the true genius of the Constitution
was separating the sovereignty from the
power and keeping those two things
separate so they can check one another
and keep an eye on one another it seems
as you move towards this bureaucratic
structure that we're talking about you
create like other tyrants you create
health problems or economic problems as
tyrants so in order to combat that you
have to like they're arguing to
recombine that sovereignty and the power
and put them in the same hands to combat
that but then we forget that fundamental
principle in the Declaration of
Independence like all men are created
equal and when weak yoke the sovereignty
and power again then we challenge that
very thing and all men are created equal
you mean yeah you're nodding what are
you going to say well we're talking
about how whether or not it the
principles of the Constitution still
apply in a radically different world but
even if it were not an agrarian society
anymore we're still a society of humans
and human nature it doesn't change we'd
still suffer from the same ills and make
the same mistakes so you're both saying
in different ways you know there's the I
think that there are 22 or 23 or
something like that million civilian
employees of the state federal and local
governments that's quite a lot the great
majority of them are state and local
employees by the way I think there might
be two three million federal employees
that's a big force and these agencies
are powerful because they are all three
branches and in their subject matter
it's just a really fearsome thing if you
get a letter from them so that's a great
power but on the other end they're human
people and they're well-meaning but your
argument is like medicines are but
you're saying that these people are not
angels right right and so if they get a
discretion sooner or later some of them
are going to abuse it
and so that means that that would
constitute some limit on how far you go
down this road the John Dewey and
Woodrow Wilson and Herbert Crawley and
these guys want us to go I'll tell you
two more problems about that I'm gonna
ask you is it possible that Dewey is
correct when he says that the principles
of the Declaration of Independence were
excellent principles for their time but
not anymore I don't think so because in
the Declaration as we mentioned it
starts off very general and very
Universal it's not talking about
anything specific to that area it moves
into particular manifestations of
violations of the general principles but
it starts off with timeless universal
truths so that means what you're saying
is if it was true then it has to be true
now and if it's false now it has to have
been false then but see here's another
thing you guys tonight we're raising
this objection to the man everybody here
except Emily you're raising the
subjection to the man that some things
don't change and they're specific one
we're talking about the most is human
beings capacity to dominate one another
you're saying that doesn't change and
you're saying that's nature the
excellence of the human being is nature
and the followings of the human being
our nature and nature doesn't change
because we remember we defined this term
nature right and this term nature
governs it starts with babies it starts
with seeds but that it includes this
fallenness of human beings right this
capable of greatness capable of evil
both and that arrangement of government
and if you set out to overcome that then
here's the final question if you can
design your child any way you want to or
your society any way you want to
what standard will you use to design it
Hitler was big into huge Enix he wanted
blond hair and blue eyes which he did
not have and he wanted the great
assertive people who would at the same
time obey everything he said no Jews
allowed right and they were working on
that that was a project so what if we
have a project like that and we exclude
nature or for that matter God and we say
we're going to take control we can make
everything better the question arises
what do you mean by better
what can give you any guidance I can
tell you what happened in Nazi Germany
right because then they just go right
down this road and what it means is the
guide that remains after everything else
has been eliminated his strength only
power can arbitrate now what that means
then I argue is that these problems that
come up in societies sure enough one of
the reasons we have the government is to
help solve these problems but if we
think about it in the radically liberal
way of Emilee or any more or the more
strict constructionist way of me and
james madison we're both in the same
universe right and the reason we are is
because we understand it yeah of course
we need to make things better in society
we need to treat people as well as we
can treat them but also we have to be a
little suspicious of concentrating power
because what will be left of our ability
to live our lives when everything is
arranged for us according to the
precepts of science
we hope that you have enjoyed this this
is our best effort and a better effort
than we've made we think to make you
part of the class
Hillsdale is built on the view that the
highest things to study are known and
beautiful the God is among them that
developing a good character through and
toward studying those high things is the
best kind of human life and that this
life is only possible by people who live
in freedom and so we have an interest in
those blessings we need a free country
to do what we do we need fellow citizens
who are excellent fellow citizens
[Music]